[Music]
Sciences bought a British Cycling a
booth really focused on the same thing
which is about delivering the best
possible performance in their ears and
committed to getting the best for each
of our riders
we're in a comfortingly hooker at the
moment training for the world
championships we're on a road camp it's
actually all track based training you do
need that endurance to be able to back
up on the track day after day because
the wheel champs are all five days local
so you need to be able to perform for up
to five days if you selected for
everything 2018 really sees the
beginning of the Olympic qualification
process those World Championships going
to be a great opportunity for our
relatively to start putting a marker
down as they look forward towards Tokyo
2020 for me personally if I come off the
road I can adapt to the truck within a
couple of sessions but I found it more
difficult doing it via Boyer lounge
getting back into the road and usually
in German side of it after a big truck
says we do a lot more work than people
probably consider we have quite a
rounded balance obviously we have
different phases so maybe of different
bits the constituents whether it's
attack block or Jim Brock but we'll
always keep board volume throughout any
block still the endurance event in track
cycling essentially is still an
endurance athlete but with a lot of fast
twitch muscle fibers so you tend to
sprint our you tend to be naturally
quick kind of like more of one of the
powerful guys row dragon tell me more
about cornering and descending and that
sort of thing whereas on the track it's
more about the whole race you need to be
positioned well for the whole race of
the back roads and the road there's may
be times you can get away with being 40
positions as long as you are at the
right times in the right place the
biggest change I have my nutrition it's
award say a major competition is quite
often taking their stress out of it
getting a habit of really simple meals
trying to just reduce faff around
training times with us such times and
sport products whether it's shakes after
training bars or just fit in your back
pocket for throughout rides and things
with the right nutrition strategy you
can make it the best that it can be in
terms of you know there is a tight turn
around sometimes especially in events
like the omnium and that's where science
and sport for us really consist of the
body you know the whey protein gel is a
fantastic product we use on the road and
the same as in the saturated it with
carbon the protein you're getting
everything
in there and it's quite late on the guts
and easy to digest which means that when
you go into your next race you're not
feeling too sluggish on race day I tend
to have more caffeine use the caffeine
gels more and you'd have extra gels you
don't want to be sort of lacking in
carbohydrates and registers it's
difficult to back up rides and do kind
of multiple intense races as soon as you
finish the first race it's important to
get a proper protein shake and some
carbohydrates into your body to make
sure that kind of recovery takes place
is perfect possible and you build up in
stefanos I eat more science and Sport
gels to kind of get my carbs kind of
tops up and then after that second race
I'll have another protein shakes and
whey isolate to keep the recovery going
athletes individually the Raiders are
responsible of course but will put in
their body so having a science and
sports supplement that comes with that
trusted in the sport validation is
really important for British Cycling
you